Well, there it is.
My beloved California
absolutely blanketed by smoke.
Somehow both apocalyptic and
beautiful at the same time.
Some would say it's not the best idea
to head right into this,
least of all during a freaking pandemic.
But here I am, with my mask collection,
double pumps of hand sanitizer,
in my RV bubble that contains
these two fine companions.
Like me, they've been tested,
layered with protocols
and chosen to interact with the world.
Our mission is to head out on Route 395.
It's a road that runs down
California's eastern spine,
and that offers up unfair
amounts of spectacular sites,
the kinds of things that
still produce wonder
amid a smoky haze.
I mean, come on!
Along the way we'll be visiting some
of the tech world's outliers,
people that like to live
and work on the frontier.
They're folks trying to
feed the planet, fix it,
or if need be,
just get off it.
If thinking different is your thing,
then here we go.
Show us the way, rented RV,
with your included dashboard ornament.
Show us the way.
We're going 45 in a 70.
Is that as fast as it goes?
No, it's just going uphill, I'd say.
If you're gonna drive an RV
through a fiery hellscape
during a pandemic,
you wanna be sure and
do it right alongside
a massive active fault system.
In this case, may I
present the Walker Lane,
which is often found hugging Route 395.
While not as well known as,
say, the San Andreas fault,
it's the Walker Lane that
gives 395 much of it's charm.
We're talking hot springs,
extinct volcanoes and mountains.
And we're talking more apocalypse,
because it's now thought
that the Walker Lane
may result in Reno ending
up as a beach town.
Who predicts such things?
Well, for one, this man.
Geologist James Faulds,
who forced me to climb this hill near Reno
to learn about the fault.
We are in the middle of
what's called the Walker Lane,
and it's a big belt of
faults in Western Nevada,
also Eastern California.
The San Andreas accommodates
about 80% of the motion
between the Pacific and
North American plates,
and about 20, maybe as
much as 25% of that motion
is over here on the Walker Lane.
Faulds is one of a growing
number of geologists
who've become obsessed
by the Walker Lane fault
and what it could mean
for residents of California and Nevada
in the distant future.
People focus so much on
the San Andreas fault
and what this could
mean in 10 million years
to the geography of the
United States and California,
but there is the potential
that this fault could
be even more dramatic
if some of these theories are right.
We know the Walker Lane
is growing northward,
along with the San Andreas,
so they are scheduled
to meet somewhere off
the Southern Oregon coast
in about maybe seven
or eight million years.
And what does that look like?
Well, when that happens,
what some of us think will occur
is that the entire San Andreas
then will rip up through
the western part of
North America, or the US,
and it'll stray on
California off to the west.
I mean, the Pacific Ocean ends
up kind of rushing through
parts of Nevada, right?
Well,
Or is this controversial?
That will be a slow process,
but we have beach-front
property in Reno someday.
This fault also brings along
some opportunities, right?
We have these crustal
motions in the region,
and in Nevada there's a
stretching of the crust,
stretching in the horizontal dimension.
And that helps to kinda
dilate or open up faults,
and that brings hot water
up closer to the surface,
and then that can be tapped
for geothermal energy.
What's that, Jim?
Did you say geothermal energy?
Well, then, let's have a
brief musical interlude
as we gaze upon the nearby
geothermal plant of Ormat.
It's got everything.
Awesome fans, I mean really awesome fans,
wells that tap into geothermal brine
10,000 feet underground,
sweet, sweet pipes and transmission lines,
turbines that you can't really see
on either side of this generator,
enough juice for 22,000 homes.
The Walker Lane fault in action.
Back to you, Jim.
And then part of the reason
there was any controversy,
or we didn't even know
that much about this fault,
was 20 years ago it was
much harder to gather data
about this kinda thing.
The fault wasn't as clear
when you looked down.
And so what is this device?
This is a GPS station.
So it's actually
communicating with satellites.
Its position is changing through time,
and those satellites are
tracking those changes
down to the scale of millimeters.
How many are monitoring the fault?
There's 400 of these
sensors in this region
in a network called Magnet.
These stations allow us
to focus in on maybe what
the most important part
of the region might be.
Like, how much activity are
people around here seeing
as result of the fault?
Nevada is the third most
seismically active state,
after Alaska and California.
After our chat James drove off
and left me with that unique
brand of existential dread
that comes from learning about
the perils of your surroundings
and what will befall humankind.
To get rid of all that
I had only one option,
a night spent
at the splendid Grand Sierra
Resort and Casino RV Park,
where, as it turns out,
you can still get DoorDash
and eat your sorrows away.
Right, let's see what it says.
Define JB.
Google maps will get you
close to the mailbox,
but not exactly there.
Expect a long gravel driveway.
You got it?
Yeah.
From Reno we headed south to Carson City.
Well, like the outermost
edge of Carson City,
where an old friend is engineering
a most unique existence.
Today, we're a little bit
outside of Carson City, Nevada.
Going to the house of JB Straubel.
He's a guy I've known for a long time.
He was one of the first
employees at Tesla,
and the long-time chief
technology officer.
I always thought of him as
the heart and soul of Tesla,
because he was this guy who,
even before Tesla was a real thing,
he was obsessed with solar powered cars,
with taking lithium ion batteries
and using them to one day
reshape the automotive industry.
He was kind of the dreamer
behind the technology,
the whole electric car revolution.
A couple of years ago
he decided he was gonna go out on his own
and start a new company
around recycling all
these lithium ion batteries
that he helped create.
We're gonna learn a little
bit more about his life,
and then we're gonna go see
his new factory as well.
Hey, guys, how are ya?
How are ya?
I'm good.
Thanks for letting us do all this.
You've, like, always,
constantly got some
project going on at home,
or one or another?
I mean, I love building things
and I kinda do this stuff to relax.
This is the current project.
Yeah, this is just sort
of a side, fun project,
but it's an interesting experiment
in being able to do this
cheaply and quickly,
and find ways to deploy solar
without heavy equipment.
And it's just fun.
And then even though you
ran Tesla's energy division,
you're building your
own battery pack, right?
I don't know.
I find more fun in the process, you know?
You can pay someone to do something,
and then it's just done.
But I think it's almost more the journey
and the mental exercises
thinking through it.
JB started coming out here
as Tesla began building
its massive giga factory battery plant.
Year by year the charms
of Nevada grew on him
and he decided to stop living in hotels
and take over this fine compound.
Over the years, Elon Musk has gotten all
of the Tesla love and adoration.
Meanwhile, JB quietly did
this thing in the background.
Always a tinkerer and engineer at heart,
he spearheaded many of
Tesla's key projects
before leaving the company in 2019.
You come from a long line of tinkerers.
Tell me a little bit about
your dad and your grandparents.
My great-grandfather actually
immigrated here from Germany
and started an engine company
in Green Bay, Wisconsin.
And he actually built machines,
some of the very first
internal combustion engines
for boats back then, for fishing boats.
I mean, it must be in
the blood to some degree,
'cause you were tinkering
from, like, what?
When you were a teenager,
or even before that?
I just enjoy it.
It wasn't necessarily a means to an end,
it was just something fun to do.
And building things, taking stuff apart,
it's, yeah, it's what I do for fun,
even in the early days.
I still remember my dad taking
me on tours of power plants
when I was, you know, like this tall
and didn't know quite
what I was looking at,
but I thought it was all super-cool.
And actually really loved
chemistry in high school.
That was probably my
favorite subject back then.
And I had built a whole
chemistry lab in the basement,
and was trying to learn
about all that on my own,
and understand batteries
and electrochemistry stuff,
even back then.
You went to Stanford.
And at Stanford you worked on,
obviously, this carried over,
'cause you ended up working
on the solar racing team.
Did you feel like there
was a revolution coming,
or this was just something
that was interesting to you?
Well, it felt early.
Things hadn't taken off,
and it was very, you know,
almost contrarian, a little bit,
thinking about solar and solar car racing
and this kind of stuff.
I had a inkling that we were
kind of at the beginning
of that transition,
and you could clearly see the potential.
Overlapping into the end of that
is when I was spending much more time
really digging in
to the earliest days
of electrical vehicles,
and starting to think more
about lithium ion batteries.
And the solar car racing stuff
was really the first on-road application
of anything like that.
At some point there was a race
and the team ends up
crashing at your house,
and this was right when
the lithium ion batteries
were turning up in all these
consumer electronic devices.
JB, tell me the story,
wasn't this the moment
where you guys were,
"Maybe we could lash all
these things together."
I was actually living in
Los Angeles at the time,
in Glendale, and it was
only a few miles away
from where the race ended.
I called my buddies and was
like, "Oh, come on over.
It's fun.
We'll hang out and you can
all crash in the living room."
So we ended up staying
up most of the night
reminiscing about the race
and talking about the
technology and how it worked.
And, you know, hatched this crazy project
to build a long-range electric car,
ditch the solar panels
and just see if we could
drive almost a thousand miles
on electricity alone.
It really, I just fell in love with it.
And it was such a fun project.
It just felt like it had to be done.
I saw no one else doing it,
and wanted to throw myself into it.
And in those days Southern
California was kind of the Mecca
for the early stages of
electric cars and batteries,
so it was a good place to be in.
You ended up with this
guy, Martin Eberhard,
and Marc Tarpenning.
They wanna make an
all-electric sports car.
You've got Elon down in LA,
he's also kinda interested in this idea
and happens to have a lot of money.
And eventually these forces combine,
and then you're right there
at the very beginning as well.
They were some of the best
times, thinking back on it.
But it also,
you know, we had no idea
what we were up against,
and trying to imagine
what it would become.
You know, it was just a handful of people,
and no one had ever
tried this stuff before,
and that was the beginning
of how we started
to understand large format batteries
and how to architect the safety of that.
So that was the challenge, right?
I mean, you guys were worried
about, obviously, the fires,
and then how you cool these things.
And there were explosions
in the neighborhood.
It was a lotta trial and error.
I mean, we were fearless and
we just plunged into this,
knowing that somehow we'd
figure this stuff out.
But, yeah, we kinda built
it off the experience
that came out of even those
earlier solar car experiments,
but scaled it way up.
And had the support of a
growing engineering team,
and, you know, more and
more interest and focus
to really create what became the Roadster.
Well, this is a really old Roadster.
This was actually one of our
first engineering prototypes.
Engineering Prototype
5 is what we called it,
so a little bit before we
started serious production.
Years ago we refurbished it,
and I sort of collected this thing
and I've taken care of it since.
I believe it's the oldest
Tesla that's on the road still.
Does it give you PTSD, or?
No, only fond memories.
It's a great thing,
to get in there and
remember what we're like
not that long ago,
and it's incredible how fast
the development has happened.
These days JB is all about batteries
and what we should do with them.
He left Tesla to start Redwood Materials.
At its heart it's a
battery recycling company,
but looked at another way
it's sort of like a
lithium or nickel mine,
just in reverse.
Sort of a startling amount of phones.
This is a big bit of phones, man!
Oh, yes.
One of many!
Redwood has a lot of batteries.
I believe the technical term is a ton.
Consumers send them in,
so do companies.
This is basically some
of the incoming material
that we get from consumers.
So it's a whole variety of stuff.
Just 18-650s, scooter battery pack,
even power tool battery packs.
It's like a power pack thing,
you know, but this has a battery in it.
So it's difficult to dispose of,
and we can recycle this for the materials.
We're inventing the ways
that you can basically recycle this
without having a human do it,
'cause it's too small.
How much lithium that's been used in here
would you guys be able to recover?
Like, what's the reuse percentage?
Almost all of it.
You know, lithium may be more than 80%,
your nickel, 95, 98%.
Same with cobalt and copper.
So it's a pretty complete process.
Redwood gets devices,
takes out the batteries,
and then begins breaking them down
into their elemental parts.
This is largely done
through heat, serious heat,
which is why these spacemen are needed.
They're using an oven
to create what is basically metal magma,
which then goes into a tub
and is stirred with a rake,
because, why not?
Redwood then goes through
chemical and other processes,
to end up here,
mounds of stuff that was
once pulled from the ground
and can now be reused.
So we got some more metal over here.
Yeah, this is just a small
batch of lithium carbonate
that we just made this morning,
and this is sort of a chance to see
what the final product is
and what lithium actually looks like
once you extract it from the batteries
and separate it out.
So this stuff is quite
pure lithium carbonate,
so this is actually the input precursor
of how lithium gets used and
built back into batteries.
It is pretty neat to see
it separated like this,
and know that this came from batteries
that were, you know, otherwise garbage
and otherwise wouldn't
have been recovered.
I mean, it's like the lithium,
say it's been in my phone,
and you guys refine it,
how many times can that happen?
Can this just keep going on and on and on?
There's no real limit to it.
There's no degradation that happens
to those atoms of lithium
or cobalt or nickel.
And it's one of the
coolest things about this,
is that those metals are
basically infinitely recyclable.
Except for the small amounts that get lost
in the recycling process itself,
you can basically keep doing
that again and again and again.
So you can start to imagine a future
where you're thinking,
"Ha, if we can do this a thousand times,
the need for mining new
materials starts to dwindle."
That's cool.
After a hard day of alchemy,
JB will head home and
tend to his nerd garden.
That might mean expanding the solar farm
or fiddling with his
homemade mountain-top internet repeaters.
Or, obviously, letting that still-running,
sexy yellow Roadster loose.
Remember, kids, study hard, work hard,
find a super-rich friend
with a Mars fetish
who believes in electric
cars just as much as you do,
and this could all be yours too.
On the next Hello World
we meet a guide who knows
California's best-kept secrets,
and find some robots working
the Central Valley's farms.
Ashlee, we just watched part
one of a three-part series
of you taking Hello World on the road,
Highway 395 on the eastern
side of California.
Tell us a little bit about
what we're expecting to see
over the course of the three episodes,
and what we just saw in this one.
First of all,
part of it's just pretty scenery,
'cause 395 is this amazing road
that, obviously, takes you
from desert and Death Valley
up to giant mountain peaks.
And, obviously, lots of
people in California know it,
but maybe outside of California
this is not one of the
things that jumps up.
But it's some of the most beautiful spots.
And then the scientists and
inventors and cubatties,
they kind of match up with the terrain.
It's like all these
people that like to be,
basically, sorta off the grid,
and doing things out where it's
dusty and sandy and gritty,
and getting dirty.
Did you know about the Walker Lane faults,
before we do that?
No, I had never,
and, okay, and this is embarrassing,
because I grew up in California,
I had never heard of
the Walker Lane fault.
I grew up in the Bay area,
so it's like the,
Hayward Falls is a big one there.
I feel like we talked about it a lot,
because it ran near my
childhood house in Fremont.
And I love the scenery of
the Eastern Sierra, so--
Yeah.
Moved by just seeing, like,
how that was created by
the deep geology under
the earth, is pretty cool.
The director, David Nicholson,
who you can see in the episode,
you know, he was the one
who was telling me about this fault,
and I'm like, "I haven't
even heard of this, man.
I mean," "how big of a deal can this be?"
And then I start reading about it
and I was like, "Oh, god, this could be
in some ways more dramatic
than San Andreas."
And then there was this whole,
we get into it a little
bit in the episode,
but if anyone wants to go read online.
Our geologist, James,
he's kinda like part of a
semi-controversial camp,
they're like the Walker Lane fault people,
as opposed to the San Andreas fault.
And so I think, especially
in the last the 20 years,
it seems there's been
a lot of debate about
how big the fault actually
is and how much it's moving.
And so all this technology just
in the last couple of years
has helped them bolster their case,
that the Walker Lane fault is a big deal.
But, yeah, I didn't know
there was faults politics
among geologists until
we really got into this.
Yeah.
I just thought your interview
with JB was really good.
It sounds like probably he's been someone
you've talked to for a long time.
When did you first meet him?
Well, yeah, so JB is one of these guys
that he's been there since
the beginning of Tesla.
And so he was kinda always in there,
in the news stories.
And then I got to know him better
when I started writing a
book about Tesla's history,
and Elon and SpaceX and all that stuff.
And I just thought, from
the first time I met him
it just struck me that
this guy was really,
you know, he was sort of the passion part
of the lithium ion battery,
is it going electric,
and all the climate change,
kinda like all the reasons
you would wanna make
an electric car company.
It actually meant something
really deep to this guy,
'cause he'd been doing it
since he was in university.
And then, obviously, if
you work for Elon Musk
and any of his companies,
it's just, like, Elon was
getting all the attention.
And I sort of think that's why it worked
for JB to stay at Tesla so long,
is that he never really sought attention
or wanted any of the limelight,
so that usually works pretty well
if you're willing to stay in the shadows.
But now he's started his own company,
and I just felt like,
well, he's an interesting guy.
He's humble, he's smart,
and then he's the sort of a
guy who deserved some attention
and to have some of his story told.
I don't think a lot of people
have heard this stuff before.
And I saw that his company only announced
what they were doing a
couple of months ago.
So did you know he was working
on something like that,
and then were waiting
for when they were ready
to talk about it,
or how did that come together?
Yeah. It was public when he left Tesla.
And even when he left Tesla,
he was like, "I'm gonna go do something
vaguely to do with battery recycling,"
but he wasn't real specific.
And then just when we were
producing this episode
he had reached out to me and was like,
"We're gonna finally tell everyone
exactly what we're doing."
And I was like, "Oh, great,
this is perfect timing.
We'll come be the first
film crew to film it all."
And then it ended up being like,
I think further along than I expected.
I mean, especially when
you see the big factory
in that footage.
It was pretty massive in person.
And he's always pretty humble,
you know, he sells himself okay,
but maybe not like some other people.
It seemed like they're doing all right.
They might actually pull this off.
It seems like the main problem
is getting the cost of,
like, it's presumably pretty
expensive to recycle lithium,
and you would just want it to make sense
for a company to choose to do that,
rather than mining something new.
He talks about it in the episode a bit,
but seeing it firsthand
you could just tell that the
variety of all these batteries
is such a pain.
And I kept asking.
It just struck me still
like a very manual process.
I couldn't see how you would have a robot
that could adjust to all
these different battery sizes
and the way you would strip them out,
and I felt like he never fully answered
that question really clearly,
and I tried to hit him with
it three or four times.
And yet I didn't see a ton
of people in the factory.
And so I was trying to
figure that piece out.
I mean, he kept talking about
how they obviously need to automate
that part of the process,
but that seemed like the
trickiest thing, to me,
that they'll have to figure out.
How long were you on the
road for the whole trip?
The whole trip was roughly 10 days.
And, yeah, full RV the whole time,
which was cool.
I mean, I always enjoy going overseas,
but it's great when you can
go explore your backyard.
And also, full confession,
which is a shameful confession,
I don't like exploring
California as much as I should.
We have all this stuff right here,
and I'd been to Death
Valley and bits and pieces
of the 395, Yosemite and things like that,
but I had never really explored it.
And so, yeah, it was a
great excuse to go do that,
get out the office,
get out of the house